China's fastest-growing coronavirus
outbreak took a startling turn for the
worst overnight
health officials confirm more than
15,000 new cases in just one day after
switching to new diagnosis methods
china's death toll rose by 254 reaching
more than 1300 people so that more than
doubled the previous highest number of
deaths in a single day doctors in the US
have confirmed the 14th case of the
virus in this country and the patient is
quarantined at the Miramar Marine Corps
Base in San Diego after being evacuated
on this flight from China last week
American companies doing business in
China including Ford and Apple have
closed factories and retail locations
because of the outbreak supply chains
for products from cars to smartphones
are disrupted and flights and cruises
are being canceled CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here to show
us what this could mean for consumers
and our investments Jill good morning so
loss of money doesn't compare to loss of
life however this is a broader and and
still growing impact absolutely and I
think that it's really important to note
that that you know we're talking about
this because there will be real people
on the ground
all over the world who would be impacted
by this economically so how will it come
back and hurt consumers well I think
there's a few different ways we know
that as you said in the introduction
that there are a lot of American
companies who get parts for their
various devices in China so I know we
think about Apple and the iPhone but
also think about maybe your VR oculus
headset maybe it is a game console
there's also some really interesting
evidence that the healthcare sector
could be impacted a lot of drugs and
medical devices from China so that's
incredibly important we know that car
makers get a lot of their parts there we
know that Tesla's Goods could actually
see some productions probably affecting
the American companies here and the
question is whether they're gonna pass
along any increase in cost to us and
that's really the question that will
depend how long they have to shut down
that's exactly right now the other thing
that's interesting there's sort of like
a good side bad side to this because
obviously China consumes a ton of oil so
oil prices have been down that's not
good for a US oil producer but that's
good for consumers we saw actually gas
prices down by 12 cents in the month of
January so there could be a silver
lining they're actually worried about
your 401ks you just sit tight for now or
start making moves well first of all the
stock market closed at all-time highs
yesterday so investors are basically
saying look this is not a big deal it's
gonna be short-lived we'll see what
happens I think if you are a long-term
investor you do nothing you stick to
your game yeah but China's China spends
a lot of money here if China tips into
recession
does that come back and hit us it could
right now economists are expecting that
Chinese growth will drop from about a 6%
annualized pace to 5% here in the US the
numbers are not nearly that significant
we're talking about 1/10 maybe a
two-tenths of a percentage point of
growth I think the big issue here in the
u.s. is certainly the travel industry is
getting hit very hard Chinese come here
to the United States and spend a lot of
money some estimates are that they will
now spend about 6 billion dollars less
on tourism
so that hurts people in on the
restaurant industry the the tour
industry it is incredibly important to
know that these things are likely to be
short term but if it goes on longer
we'll be back here talking about the
impact potential impact yeah but again
nothing as serious as the potential
lives lost enjoy thank you so much